[Music]
an outpouring of support for louisiana
and his bid for a third presidential
term
[Applause]
thousands of supporters cheered lula as
he held his first campaign rally in
brazil's largest city sao paulo at the
same place where thousands of brazilians
defied the military regime back in 1984
demanding democratic elections
i'm here to support lula but especially
brazil's democracy which is at risk
president jail barcelona has been
casting doubts on our voting system
preparing his followers to cry out fraud
if he's defeated
polls show left wing lula is ahead of
his far right adversary president jair
bolsonaro who is running for a second
term in october's election
[Applause]
be prepared bolsonaro brazilian voters
will kick you out of the presidency you
can say that if you lose you'll not hand
over the presidential sash because the
people will make sure you do
while lola portrays himself as a
champion of democracy bolsonaro
supporters have turned the election into
a battle between good and evil
the president defends traditional family
values and his wife an evangelical
christian says her husband was chosen by
god
[Applause]
the state should have no religion
churches should preach about faith not
politics nor should they defend
candidates and false prophets
but one third of brazil's population is
struggling to put food on the table
brazil's may be latin america's largest
economy but years of recession followed
by the kovit-19 pandemic and the war in
ukraine have put the country back on the
united nations hunger map
and fixing the economy is dominating the
national debate more than any other
issue monika yanakiv al-jazeera